[Musique]
Ensuite, vous êtes incroyable de comprendre que je suis
sérieux, vous l'avez fait sans
vous tenir à côté dans le magasin de démarrage que vous lancez,
avez-vous trouvé parce que je me
sens en ce moment
ouais oh ouais allons manger
là-bas,
gardez votre  tête maintenant
[Musique]
alors je t'ai parlé de mon frère ouais
quelque chose s'est passé je ne sais pas exactement
ce que tu ne devrais pas arrêter est détenu
à Rikers Island oh mon dieu c'est affreux
hé tu dois juste le faire sortir de là
avant quelque chose de mauvais  se produit si vous êtes
tué dans cette
autre subvention de 10 autres, vous obtenez 10
000 autres, votre frère révélera la
vérité
Je suis dedans
et mener une Pure Life
regarde devant dans un ciel clair n'y arrivera pas
mais c'est un beau rêve
c'est un beau rêve
[Musique]
toi